gentlemen we're live oh we're live we'll
not take a girl well we're live folks
you missed some good stories here about
where adam uh uh was conceived it's his
yeah
anyways today we have a special guest
with us very special yes we have a
special guest with us former governor of
illinois the fifth largest economy i
believe in america governor ron rod
blagojevich who also ended up
um
going to out of the 24 counts one of
them you were found guilty and you ended
up going to jail i think for 168 months
but you only served eight of it because
you were pardoned by president trump and
we'll get into that as well
and uh a lot's changed from then to now
but uh it's good to have you on the
podcast i'm glad we were able to pull
this off well thanks very much for
having me appreciate you guys and
congratulations on your success welcome
to america you're the american dream in
my next life i want to be you
i don't want to be me
i know it's crazy
and by the way on this podcast you can
you can you can be free to curse you
don't have to worry about it so i saw
your video and i did the video the
documentary starts off saying there's
going to be be careful there's you know
what kind of language they say excessive
use of a
found language and then they give you
the disclaimer and then he gives it to
you to start off the the
the documentary last night i'm up these
guys he tells me about the uh
documentary i'm like i'm gonna try to
watch it so last night dinkin comes over
we're talking about the next book and we
had an hour and a half session then we
watched all-star game in fourth quarter
because i don't miss the fourth quarter
second fourth quarter the way he
finished it was sick michael jordan
there all that stuff and then i had to
sit there and watch your documentary
till 1 30 in the morning and then i was
with my trainer this morning at six
o'clock so i have eight hours of sleep
okay condensed in four hours is what i
did but for some people that don't know
you you're from yugoslavia your family
is your father i believe is from
yugoslavia and i was a when i was at
germany at a refugee camp one of the
families we got very close to were
yugoslavian
his name was miodrag yeah miodrak and
the wife's name was ana maria and the
daughter's name is ana maria they're in
canada now but i remember spending time
with them we had a lot of things in
common escaping the kind of life that we
had but for for folks who don't know who
you are if you don't mind taking a
moment and sharing your story with them
that'd be great sure well thank you
first of all let me say my dad spent
three years in a refugee camp after
world war ii waiting for the united
states congress that one day his
youngest son that'd be me passed a law
called the displaced persons act which
allowed my father and millions of others
like him with these long and hard to
pronounce last names a chance to come to
america so my late father had something
come with you because you spent a couple
of years right in a refugee camp in
germany
um look in so many ways in fact it was
my life was the american dream my mother
and father were working people my mom
was american born
if she'd have come from the old country
like my dad i think my first name would
have been as hard to pronounce as my
last name i'd never been the governor of
illinois but then again i'd never been
inmate number
nine two four two four
but my life's been
the american dream because of the
success that i was fortunate to have
because so many people helped me then it
was the kafka nightmare that came after
it when i was sent to prison was
compelled to shelter in place for eight
years for politics not for crimes from
what the wall street journal called
practicing politics
but you know the values that made you so
successful
patrick are the values my mother and
father instilled in me that you're
fortunate and lucky to live in a great
country like this a land of opportunity
it's supposed to be a land of freedom
it's a fragile gift that we have that we
shouldn't take for granted i've learned
some hard lessons about that
but it's a place where if you dream you
can reach those dreams if you're
prepared to work hard to make those
dreams real i've been working since i
was nine years old shining shoes
and um i'm still working and when i was
in prison it's funny because i was
earning about 5 and 25 cents a month in
prison i earned more money as a
nine-year-old shining shoes in chicago
than i made as a former governor in my
early 60s and a lawyer and a lawyer and
and all the rest so you know i've been
up i've been down but there's an old
irish proverb that says even god can't
make two mountains without a valley in
between so i'm climbing back up and it's
fun as you know the journey is even more
fun than the destination so what's next
for you what do you mean yeah i watch
your i watch the documentary and here's
one of the things i notice about you
it didn't matter when it was whether
it's you're walking out and you're about
to go to jail you're shaking hands hey
you're hugging this lady and your wife's
to your left and you're hugging you're
kissing on the cheek and you're hugging
this other lady
you're always in in campaign mode have
you always been this guy that's shaking
hands building relationships have you
always been that guy
you know i don't know you know i guess
so i don't know maybe yes maybe no i
when i was shining shoes i know when i
was a kid in order to get the tips you
gotta hustle right you gotta get out
there and schmooze a little bit and try
to do a good job shining shoes and try
to keep the black shoe polish off the
the white sox of the guy who's an
engineer who shouldn't be wearing white
socks or black shoes right um they
should fire that guy
or maybe he's a fan of jerry lewis i
think jerry lewis used to do something
like that he used to wear white socks
with black shoes right that's right
those old movies
um but
you know i i uh
i guess so you know i wasn't exactly
great in school i went to public school
in chicago i wasn't set the world on
fire schools who were you in high school
like if we were in high school together
who was who was if i asked one of your
classmates that was in high school with
you 10th grade 11th grade who was rod
somebody who didn't do so good in
physics and got a d in algebra which was
a classic case of great inflation
um
you know i played on the high school
basketball team at boss golden gloves in
chicago first time ever got my name in
the newspaper chicago tribune was the
golden globes when i was 17 18 years old
i grew up a real city life in a big city
like chicago
but i was lucky to have great parents
that you know work hard and sacrifice so
i can go to college and it was them
their hard work and sacrifice that gave
me a chance to
get up high in politics now as i said
looking back
it's a mixed blessing in view of what's
happened but i do believe and i had
2896 days to think when i was sheltering
in place in prison
and i do believe god has a plan for all
of us and i think as bad as that was
as is written in genesis what they meant
for evil god meant for good and i feel
like there's some service that i can
still provide as well as working hard to
build a better life for my daughters and
my wife
you know i i watched uh your story and i
watched all the clips read all the
stories that's out there so i've seen
the good bad and the ugly about you
and
i see the love and hate relationship
there are those who hate you and i i
called some friends and these are guys
that are in business who are from
chicago
and i said tell me what you think about
this guy
and they said uh well let me tell you
who he is you know there are people here
that like him there are people here that
think he's innocent there are people
here that think he's guilty
but
it was a mixture it wasn't just all good
and all bad
some people that i thought were going to
be saying nothing but bad things about
you were like no this guy was actually
trying to do some stuff but he got
caught doing what everybody else does
and he went to jail for it those the
other guys didn't and then some of the
guys i talked to they just said pat
don't let him fool you he's a
you know charmer charismatic this this
that you have to understand where he's
at he's a very good persuader so
why this love-hate relationship with you
well isn't that the case when you take
strong positions i mean with all due
respect if if you were
not those things that means you didn't
stand for anything right franklin
roosevelt said you have enemies good
that means you stood for something and
uh you know i think as governor i was
the first democrat governor 26 years
elected in illinois but i didn't want to
raise taxes on the people my party loves
to raise taxes on regular people we
claim to be the party of the little guy
and working people but every chance the
democrats in illinois get they keep
checking up taxes that's why illinois is
the highest tax state in the nation so i
was determined to invest more money in
health care and provide health care to
kids and other families
do things like free public
transportation for our seniors which we
did preschool for three and
four-year-olds and a lot of other
initiatives without raising taxes on the
people which meant to pay for those
things you got to move the money around
that means you're taking it away from
others who've benefited from it and when
you do that you piss them off
so i think a lot of it had to do with
the establishment came after me
and you know i sat in prison and watched
with horror
what the same people using the same
playbook were trying to do to president
trump and what they did to me a democrat
governor at the aaa level they tried to
do at the major league level to a
republican president fortunately he was
able to beat it because he had
you know a lot more support and he had
the ability of the oval office and the
bully pulpit that the president has that
governors don't have
but it's the same thing and this is very
scary for our democracy it's not a
democrat or republican issue it's an
american issue it goes to the heart of
our freedoms we the people should choose
our leaders in free fair and honest
elections and not have them have the
choices taken away from us by corrupt
prosecutors who would criminalize legal
things i didn't break a single law and
yeah you have those naysayers over there
in chicago everything i did was legal
they were conversations that began
because president-elect obama sent an
emissary to me to make a political deal
about the senator he wanted the person
he wanted picked his senator we
discussed what we could get in that
political deal all legal
i mean
i got to d in algebra i'm not claiming
to be the smartest guy in the room but
i'm not that stupid how do you
steal a senate seat when you're the
governor and get away with it you can't
be that stupid and that you don't mind
me swearing right now you're fine you
guys are golden
so um but go back go back to that when
you're saying go ahead right so you know
they expected they what they did was the
prosecutors did they
they brought shock and awe i was roger
stone before roger stone in other words
they came to my house with swat teams at
six o'clock in the morning and the ninth
of december 2008 i'm a sitting governor
you don't arrest a governor or anybody
unless the person's threat to run away
or a threat to his neighbors i was
neither one of those things but they did
it for the big show and they did it to
create an environment where they create
this
inevitable foreseeable chain of events
that would invite the media to see the
super sensational story
and run with a narrative that they fully
expect that i would just give up and
give in and cut my losses and maybe take
18 months
but i would never do it and
and so i fought back and they didn't
convict me of the first trial they tried
me a second time they used an unlawful
standard to convict me on legal things
no one even alleges that it took any
money it was all politics and the
so-called sale of the senate seat which
i'm known for was reversed by the
appellate court on the 22nd of july 2015
as i sat in prison they could never
uphold that unlawful standard they used
against me but they kept me in prison
for three fundraising requests where
there was no quid pro quo which means no
crime but they moved the line and and
instructed the jury to convict if we
asked for campaign contributions from
people or groups who had business
interests with the state which is how
politics works completely legal but i
think it was such a big deal
that somebody had to go down and you
know when you're fighting back against
that kind of power
deep down you know you're going down but
you make a decision i'm going down
fighting because as winston churchill
said nations that go down fighting come
back but those who shamelessly surrender
don't
so i think uh i think i've got a big
powerful comeback ahead of me yeah
when you're saying
you know they did this they did that
they did this who is they
can you can you define is it michael
casey is it who's they
well the u.s attorney patrick fitzgerald
who's real close with james comey these
guys worked together he was in the fbi
the
number one number two guy in the fbi
mueller was the fbi director when they
arrested me it's the same people that
were doing the trumpet they did to me
and i think president trump recognized
that and that's among the reasons why he
sent me home
and uh what was his reasoning though
because he didn't have beef with you
to start there must have been something
you have done where he said uh
something's up with that guy where did
this all initiate you know i learned as
after i was arrested i learned that they
had been investigate first of all i knew
they were investigating my
administration and me
since the very beginning when i became
governor within six months for what
reason though they were looking at some
people that that i was close to a guy by
the name of tony rusko who was close to
obama and me raised money for both of us
and uh but i had nothing to do with any
of the things that they were looking at
him at but i was well aware that they
were looking and you know you come out
of chicago politics you just assume
those people look at you
so
everything you know what i tried to do
was to make sure we were super careful
we didn't do anything to cross lines the
irony is those fbi tapes for six weeks
they were taping me
i assumed it was possible they could be
listening i was discussing the sale of
sentencing i was talking about every
possible idea so that whatever we did
was legal didn't cross lines and was the
best possible decision i could make on
something that was effing golden it was
golden you got this thing and
everybody wants it and you can make a
real good political deal that could be
helpful hopefully to people if you do it
the right way
um so it wasn't like i wasn't aware that
they were looking at me they were very
much intensely looking at me yeah so
you've seen a movie of american gangster
with uh who's in it russell crowe is in
it with denzel right am i getting the
right russell crowe right and then
there's the scene where russell crowe is
sitting there and he's got this person
at the top that he's thinking is the
main guy behind blue magic i think it's
called blue magic and you know he's the
one that's doing it and then all of a
sudden he realizes no no the guy out
there all the way at the top is
frank lucas right and frank lucas three
quarters of billion dollars during that
time of year and anyways later on he
comes in and he throws everybody else
under the bus or whatever happened with
the case at the end of the movie but so
you said fitzgerald muller you say all
these names right and the same thing
there's no trump comey right all these
names you're saying
who is the boss of them
that's like who are they supporting
who's the guy at the top when you play
the same game
i'm not even sure i know um
i i to this day i'm still trying to sort
it out and figure it out i do believe
that there was some collusion
with the democratic house speaker and
chairman of the party michael madigan
who's now facing federal intense federal
housing investigation i do believe there
may there was a collusion when they
impeached me because they wouldn't allow
me to play tapes you see here's the
thing you guys
patrick and adam
they taped me for six weeks they played
snippets selected snippets of
conversation out of context to make me
look
bad this is cold and i'm not
giving it up for nothing that was the
day after the election that was the day
after i was approached by this labor
boss who said barack called me the night
before wants to talk to you about a
senate seat what do you want so i
mentioned that to my aides we discussed
what can we get for this
and there was no they don't play the
rest of the tape where
um you know the conversation is put in a
proper context do you have that do you
have the recording i have all those
tapes i've had them for years but we're
not allowed to play them publicly
because immediately after they played
those snippets and arrested me they went
right into court and got a seal order to
keep those tapes under seal and it's
against the law if you release them and
then we tried repeatedly in court to
play those tapes at the trials i was
promised by the judge in the second
trial that if i agreed to testify i
could play the tapes to corroborate my
testimony so i agreed to get up there
and testify because i knew that if i
testified the tapes the prosecutor's
gonna do exactly what he did and that is
lie to the jury and say go back to the
jury room and see how many times you
hear tapes corroborating what he says
well i get up there they won't play the
tapes to this day they won't play the
tapes and the tapes show a very
different story from what they tried to
have people believe they are lions
scumbags they're corrupt
you can say that here right yeah you
can't believe it but love you guys you
know i was watching this dude i was
watching uh uh the part where you're
like i'm gonna testify i will testify
i'm going to show you wait till you hear
it i want everybody to be up there i'm
the opposite of a you know nixon nixon
said no i want i want everything to be
out there and then when it comes down to
it you didn't testify and you said your
lawyer wanted you to testify but the
father
encouraged you to not testify because
you don't have to and you said something
if there's one thing that i'm guilty of
is sometimes i you know talk too much or
something like that he said right so
from your end i mean i've heard the
answer on the documentary unless if
there's a different answer
why didn't you eventually testify if
that's if you know you're innocent why
don't you testify right well i did at
the second trial what you're talking
about in that hulu documentary is the
first trial yeah and at that point their
case was so ridiculously
not there was no crimes that the
decision by the lawyers was
don't even bother putting a defense on
they proved nothing
and so therefore if you don't put a
defense on you can't testify so that's
what happened and
all those charges none of them were the
convict the corruption charges none of
them were convictions okay they were all
uh hung jury so they declare a mistrial
i didn't realize they can try you
forever they try a second time but we
didn't if i was successful the second
time they did tried me a third time but
so they tried me the second time and
there i testified on the promised by the
judge that if i agreed to testify i
could play the tapes to corroborate my
testimony and the judge lied and i got
up there and i wasn't allowed to play
those tapes and the prosecutor lied
directly to the jury he's a liar his
name is reed shah and i challenge him to
challenge me he went up for the jury and
lied and said you're going to testify
about the senate seat go back into the
jury room and hear how many times you
hear tapes
if there were 102 conversations on that
on the one particular subject that he
was accusing me of lying about and he
knew those tapes existed and they
wouldn't play him well governor it was a
total frame up i'm sorry no no uh
there's nothing worse than being accused
of something that you genuinely didn't
do agreed yes i mean there's nothing
worse than that and i'm not here to play
jury judge executioner that's not my job
here you know the jury was out and and
you're not
you're not admitting guilt and more
power to you if you're freaking innocent
i would be at the same position as you
but my question is knowing what you know
now what would you have done differently
there must have been something you would
like you know what
yes i'm innocent but i could have done a
little better at that what is that
look i had all those years to think
about it right
i mean i'm sitting in the higher
security prison i'm the only governor to
be in a real prison where my home was a
six foot by eight foot prison cell they
put me there for 32 months all designed
to squeeze me and try to break my will
to resist
when you're in a place like that and
then you have all those other years
afterwards you've got more than enough
time to do a lot of stuff including
think
not that healthy to think too much but
you can't help it sometimes and of
course i ask myself the same question
you asked me because
my children had been harmed my little
girls and my wife
and i asked myself did my pride get i
get so caught up in my pride that i
should have been more sensible and
willing to maybe cut my losses a little
bit and give in not so much for me but
for my kids so that i won't be gone so
long probably could have been gone 18
months they were floating that around
after the first try it was a plea deal
you're saying they were floating the
possibility of 18 months i rejected it
completely because that would require me
to plead guilty to something it's not a
crime i wouldn't do it and so i asked
myself those questions so i'm answering
your question this long way just because
i've gone through it myself many many
times and i would answer
here's how i've in my own mind i
i feel like i made the right call if i
was a businessman
and you're looking at this from a
business point of view
and your obligation is to your business
your shareholders your partners your
family as well
maybe you make a business decision you
cut your losses and you say you did
something you really didn't do or you
plead guilty to a non-existent crime
that they're criminalizing in your case
because this is what they do they take
legal stuff they turn them into crimes
that make you plead guilty to these
things
and uh maybe you do that if you're a
businessman but i was the governor of
illinois
you know you i don't politicians talk
about the bible and stuff but twice i
swore on the holy bible to serve and
protect
the constitution and the rule of law and
i was elected by the people
to do that and i i just couldn't get
over the fact that i'd be selling out
the people as well as myself if i gave
into this
plus the fact that i think i'd be a
drunk because i'd hate myself wouldn't
be able to look at i couldn't look
myself in the mirror which is something
i like to do too often
okay well you've got a great head of
hair that's uh
those are the rumors about you i'd comb
it less because i would hate myself if i
gave into it when i know absolutely
everything i did was legal and those
conversations were all about making sure
we did everything right because these
people were chasing me
so the final analysis is it's been a
long long hard journey
the hand of god reached in used
president trump as an instrument the
unlikely convergence events that trump
would have me on celebrity apprentice i
don't know if you guys know that i was
on that show and i get to know him a
little bit great guy he saw what they
were doing to me and the years would go
by he'd be the president they'd do the
same thing to him and there i'd be in
prison exhausting all of my remedies and
the guy i endorsed for president the
first governor obama
passes me by and trump's the one who
saves my ass it's remarkable well you
know obama passed passed you by because
you know i read some place some of the
comments you made about him when he said
i've done more for the black community
than he's done
and you said something about i used to
be a shoe shiner
and
you you made a few comments about obama
i think and that was made
years ago which he probably held that
against you why he didn't want to pardon
you because in every possible way no one
in a million years died your crime
should be 14 years 168 months everybody
said okay two three five years fine
14 years it's a little too much to go
away for 14 years for what you did so
that's why a lot of people you know that
i've read about it's like you know obama
should have came out and pardoned you
but i think it was a phenomenal comment
you said two years ago would you agree
or would you say it's otherwise i think
i think he passed me by because he was
involved in the case he's the one who
started the whole thing he sent someone
to me and we talked about making a deal
based upon his overture to me by sending
that labor boss to me on the night of
the election that's where it all started
that's why i think he passed me by about
that comment you're making
look
i just admitted that i wasn't so good at
algebra i also admit sometimes i say
stupid things
and i was
talking to some reporter he was doing a
esquire magazine doing a profile on me
i'd run eight miles earlier that day
hadn't eaten all day watching manny
pacquiao fight ricky hatton remember
that five years ago
and i had my host italian american guy
great guy bilkin 40 gave me this drink
called a lemoncello you ever have that
yes it's like lemonade with alcohol in
it yeah and i was thirsty because i'd
run and i hadn't eaten all day that's
why you were the governor no i was
thrown out of office by then i was in
the middle of my trials i think it was
before the first trial
and so i had that limoncello and i was a
little bit too loose-lipped and i'm
talking to this reporter you can't trust
those sons of right esquire
magazine and i'm pointing out hatton and
pacquiao especially pacquiao who have
great admiration for i like boxing and
talk about how you have to have chip get
in life you got to have a chip on your
shoulder man it starts out and it starts
in the schoolyard when you get your ass
kicked and you got this real hunger and
desire to overcome adversity and stuff
so i started going off on that then i
got into obama and here's where i said
the stupid thing not all together wrong
but you shouldn't say it as a white guy
i said i'm blacker than obama obama's
lifestyle i mean he went to hawaii he's
growing up he went to harvard
not really an inner city guy i grew up
in the heart of the city i went to
public school they wouldn't let me in
harvard they let him in and uh you know
i had those jobs
as you say shine issues and all these
other jobs just my life experience and i
did talk about how my policies were
tremendously helpful to the
african-american community i like to
think everybody else too
far more than his would ultimately be
because he could have done so much more
and he didn't so i said it in that
context but a white guy should never say
he's blacker than a black guy so i i did
apologize for that
i said it and uh
it was was around the same time that
harry reid made those comments as well
so i think harry reid made some comments
as well about him saying the reason why
he got elected because he doesn't have
the accent of uh something some uh his
dialect isn't and
do you remember this
yeah harry reid made a comment harry
reider joe biden no no it's harry reid
harry reid said the reason why obama got
elected is because he has a dialect of a
white man something like that
uh anyways okay you can find it so we
can uh
because we don't want it so go back to
it so go back to the question i asked
you and you you went one direction and
then you went to uh he asked a question
about what things you would have changed
but when you said they they they they
and i said who is they who's at the top
of they and you said fitzgerald and he
said comey and then he said you know
mueller some of these names that you
said and then now when i said why didn't
obama pardon you because you said obama
was a part of it so now let's go to that
part if obama's a part of it my
speculation becomes if obama so because
sometimes
i feel like you know uh
when jerry boss
gets a call from shaq and shaq says hey
jerry
riley and the heat offered me 20 million
a year if you match me i'll stay with
you at the lakers you know what jerry
bus told him
he said i think you should take that
offer because i can't match that offer
and what does shaq do he goes to miami
what does jerry do he locks and who kobe
right okay similar call happened when
pat riley called jerry bus and said hey
listen i'm getting a massive contract
from the knicks you want to match it
i'll stay i don't want to leave the
lakers but they're offering like five
and a half million or whatever the
number was and he's like dude i can't
pay you that you go take that contract
right i feel like at one point
and i'm seeing this trend on both
political parties when they lock on to
someone everybody becomes indispensable
right and somebody has to almost take a
blame for something so during kovid you
know the first six months the rock star
of covet was who
he was a rock star right every day we
heard cuomo cuomo como he's the next
presidential candidate him and his
brothers would go at it
and then something happened behind
closed doors that i don't think any one
of us will ever know what happened there
where he either didn't say yes or he
either thought he was bigger than the
political party pelosi and these guys
flipped on him next thing you know hey
you got to resign he resigned then his
brother boom then you know zucker boom
then uh cmo boom we saw what the trickle
effect was all the way down
do you think it was a position right
that time all these guys behind closed
doors said um
look that guy's a governor he's probably
not going to be the president this guy's
a senator he had a great speech at the
dnc in 2004. we can get behind this guy
let's back him up let's throw this guy
under the bus and let's go do you think
a conversation like that took place
beyond closed doors no i don't think so
i don't i don't think it was like that i
think it was that these federal
prosecutors some of them are just
unscrupulous
guys who abuse their power and make big
names for themselves by being big game
hunters and this guy was chasing me for
a long long time i think he was also
chasing obama because of rusco and so
when rescue got indicted on stuff that
had nothing to do with me or obama so he
was trying to get obama as well i
believe this is my belief
i'll give you my belief on how it all
shook out so what happened was because
resco was closer to obama than he was to
me he actually bought him property obama
bought a big mansion after his elected
state's united states senator and then
the lot the adjoining lot
this guy rusco bought for obama and then
when the heat was on politically obama
gave him a bill and bresco paid thirteen
thousand dollars to put a fence up but
the seven hundred fifty thousand dollar
lot that was paid at least price by
rescue was basically for obama it was
like a adjoining lot to the mansion that
he bought
so
they were looking at both of us i think
because of resco and they were right to
look at rusco there were allegations
related to stuff that he was doing
in the
in any event he finally gets convicted
rusco does and they're squeezing them to
say stuff about the two of us he puts
out a letter to the sentencing judge and
says that these federal prosecutors are
trying to make me say things about
governor blagojevich and senator obama
he actually listed me first
i'm not going to lie about those two
guys just to save myself i've never been
involved in any wrongdoing
yeah it's a matter of public record made
the front page of the chicago tribune
the big fear was would rescue lie to
save himself because they squeeze these
people
you know would scare them with long
sentences but if they'll say certain
things they want them to say sing or
compose you know then they get lighter
sentences that was the big fear but when
resco did that both of us were
in real good place that's when they
started putting the fbi tapes on me
but
then when they arrested me here's what i
think happened with obama they
immediately went to obama and they
interviewed him because he was involved
in the case and those are called fbi
302s
to this day they still won't give us my
team my lawyers the fbi 302s of obama's
interview which is absolutely relevant
to a criminal defendant me
in the facing what i was facing they
have to give you that they they didn't
and they still won't so they've got that
sort of under seal as well
i think obama made a calculation as
political people made a calculation that
when fitzgerald made that big move
arrested a sitting governor in such a
dramatic way the way he did
i was politically radioactive they did
this on purpose everybody ran it's like
the ship is sinking and the
everybody jumps overboard right obama
was no different and he was saving
himself politically not wanting to get
caught up in any of that and so they i
was sold out in the process you you seem
like a very ambitious guy very you seem
like super ambitious with a chip which i
relate to the on the underneath i would
say that's projection considering your
background
well listen that's high praise by the
way it's america no no i i see you as an
extremely ambitious guy with a very
unique quality when i'm listening to you
and you're like we're sitting there with
uh my kid my wife and amy and the girls
and i uh we go to sleep and i'm telling
them we're gonna stay strong we're gonna
stay strong and i'm not breaking i'm not
crying we're not gonna cry we're gonna
get through this because the truth is
this and all this stuff and then
you know you say we go to sleep we put
the kids to sleep and i wake up in the
morning and i woke up at four o'clock
because i was about to go away to jail
and i won't be you know 14 years and you
know i'm i'm getting and i'm still not
crying i'm not you're telling the story
you're not breaking right and then you
said i'm not going to turn around
because i've been replaying this in my
mind that if i go out the door i'm not
going to look back and i go out the door
and i look back and it was the hardest
thing i had to do my life and the next
you know the reports are out there like
this guy
is so
mentally and emotionally like he is not
gonna allow the opponent to win whether
he's right or wrong you gotta respect an
opponent like that you you got that you
got that tough skin that you can't teach
that so and that's what family because
family is emotional that's a very
difficult thing to go through
and then
you sitting here and hearing the story
with obama and you
um as a person that's extremely
ambitious with a chip on the shoulder
i'm curious to know what your answer is
going to be to this and i think i hope
it's not the the answer that i think
you're going to give but i hope you tell
the truth the real truth and i'm just
curious to know what you'll say about
this
were you at all
envious jealous upset that a one-term
senator became a president and the
governor of illinois
didn't where you felt you were more
qualified to be a president than him
i would say i was more resentful than
jealous i admire his skill right you
know he's a he gave a great speech in
boston in 2004 that catapulted him look
i had a good relationship with obama we
were in politics together in illinois he
was not close but it was good it's
friendly you're both democrats we're
both democrats on opposite sides of town
we were both pretty much the same
generation coming up at the same time
both considered rising stars in the
1990s
and uh you know i became the governor
two years before he became
senator so we were both on that
trajectory way up high you became
governor two years before he became a
senator yes so on paper you're you're
the guy
that should have the lead on running for
office more than him
yes i think so and i was a governor too
and historically governors are more apt
to be presidents than senators and fifth
largest state we're not talking governor
of like kansas right but you said
resentful so what caused the resentment
the resentment
resentment was that
i truly believe that the resco issue was
used by obama david axelrod who used to
work for me and i like axelrod look it's
politics are rough as business okay very
obvious and you know people do things to
you
on a monday they stab you in the back
and they screw you but you got to work
with them on tuesday right and so you
build up a certain immunity to this now
when calamity comes on like it did to me
and in my family at that level
it's a lot more serious
so but i think what they did was they
were dumping rescue on me making me the
guy who was closer to resco because the
feds were looking at rusco and
as obama's political aspirations were
rising and his presidential
hopes became more realistic
they were dumping tony rescue more on me
and this was a design and the media was
all over that and they were protecting
obama and screwing me
and there was sort of like an
affirmative action approach to this in
other words they were elevating him and
and making me wear all the negative
stuff and so i think that's what it was
it was more the resentment of how i was
being treated by my own party and by the
media as opposed to like a fair
assessment that both of us had some
misjudgments with a guy that we thought
was not the guy he turned out to be
so so going back to the recording in an
atom i'll turn it over to you if you got
any questions going back to the
recording that you had right because i
think the call was
rahm emanuel said here's four names pick
one of them this is who obama wants what
do you want and i think at the top of
the list was what jesse jackson jr
because when a sitting senator goes and
becomes a president the current governor
is able to appoint somebody in that seat
and a lot of times that's a leverage
point right historically that's not the
first you're not the first person i went
through this this happens regularly and
there's some kind of leverage in
negotiation sometimes it's political
sometimes it's campaign support sometime
it's an endorsement sometimes it's a lot
of different things
that you read about but the the
recording goes i got this thing and it's
uh golden right gold
and i'm not giving it up for nothing i'm
not gonna do it there's a life after
that if i do it right you guys are
telling me to sit here for two years as
a governor and do nothing everyone is
passing me by give it up for nothing and
then uh
you know he says who's passing you by
and doing you know who's doing this and
you said everybody right he wanted jesse
jackson and at the end he said only 13
percent of you think i'm doing a good
job
uh and then rahm says you know i want
jesse in anyways the problem is
how do we take some of my financial
pressure off of me that was the one
statement that you made how do we take
somebody to find out and what's funny is
even though they have that in recording
out of the 24 counts they didn't hold
you right you didn't you know you were
not found guilty for that statement
right so it was for a completely
different account something that
happened in the past donation they were
talking about earlier fundraising stuff
fundraising stuff that happened so
while you're in this moment and going
through this and you hear that the
recording is public and it's michael
casey i think that'll prove it to mike
michael you casey i don't know exactly
what his name is that's right he was the
assistant attorney general he was the
attorney general he was the one that
approved recording you and wiretapping
which by the way this goes back to
some of the things when i talked to rudy
giuliani rudy giuliani said this whole
thing with rico we changed it because
that professor from
uh rutgers universe i don't know what
university was that he said here's how
we can get the you know mob let's just
change the laws on rico and they changed
it and we know what happens with that
they were able to get the mob uh to go
away so
while you heard yourself when the
recording came public and you heard it
what was your initial reaction ouch are
you kidding me i cringed when i heard
especially the f-word i was flinging it
around by the way rahm emanuel says it
way more than i do he's on the tapes all
over the place of course you can't play
him
but uh and that's no justification
that's not any diamond against him
either it's just you know sometimes we
talk locker room
among the guys there were no women on
those calls when i was using that word
but real quick um
that was a career day call in other
words we spent two hours on that call
you couldn't play they wouldn't let us
play
any of that tape other than what they
played that snippet where i'm venting
because the discussion part of the
discussion was do i just not be governor
anymore because
uh
the fbi had gone out and ruined my
wife's real estate business by going to
all of her customers and clients and
everybody was afraid to do any business
with her so we were actually facing some
difficult financial circumstances and
the discussion was do i just no longer
stay as governor or do i stay as
governor for two years or should i make
myself a u.s senator and how does how
would that work for our family unlikely
i would ever do anything like that but
that's brainstorming and you're supposed
to be able to talk freely and honestly
in conversations they're not crimes
unless you have to do something that's
actually criminal none of those things
were you could legally make yourself a
senator i was unlikely to do it but
these were discussions that we had for
two hours on that particular call
and i was angry too because i knew these
feds were on my ass yeah i knew it and i
and i was fearful that they were going
to do everything they could to get me
because they had such a big investment
in getting me the irony is it's those
very conversations where i'm super
careful i don't do anything wrong that
they twist and take out of context and
make these things sound worse than they
are
every
i on average talk to my lawyer three
times a day when during that period of
time we could never introduce that into
evidence because i asked him can i do
this can i do that how do you do a deal
like this because everybody was coming
to me with different ideas creative
ideas and what you might want to do with
the senate seat like oprah winfrey we
discussed her for two days and whether i
should appoint her senator she wouldn't
take it but we discussed that
realistically i haven't did something
really stupid you want to hear this
which they played at the first trial
we can swear here right yes all right
and this is stupid and it's childish
i'm on the phone a bunch of guys on the
phone we're talking about i'd like
ideally to appoint a black person to the
united states senate
because obama is the only black person
he's leaving there'll be 99 100 senators
that we don't replace him with somebody
who's african-american no black people
united states senate in the age of obama
so i would like one ideally but i don't
want the usual old people in politics
and you know some people
you know they have their own agenda
you know i'm asking my chief of staff to
find me
a black person with a strong military
background somebody like that who's not
known let's keep thinking creatively and
think outside the box so then i do this
stupid thing
i say hey quinlan he's my lawyer hey
quinlan what's the law again about
residency to be a a senator how long do
you got to live in illinois he says you
got to live in illinois for one day you
got to be 30 years old and you it's okay
if you're a naturalized citizen so then
i say hey why doesn't somebody reach out
to halle berry in hollywood ever moved
to illinois for one day i'll make her a
senator maybe i could her
you say this i say this of course i'm
not doing any of this this is just
childish ridiculous locker room talk
with a bunch of guys so there i am at
the first trial okay
and boy that's a bad place to be and
they're playing these tapes okay yeah
and you got this big notebook in front
of you and you can look leaf ahead and
see what they what they're going to play
next what they're going to play next i
don't remember half of this stuff okay
so i'm looking ahead it's about 11 40 in
the morning generally the judge will
break for lunch at noon media's all over
the place every day right my devoted
loving wife there in the front row right
by her husband my wife patty
and uh
i look ahead and whoa and i see here
comes that they're gonna play the halle
berry tape it's got no relevance it's
just gonna be designed to prejudice the
jury against me okay
and cause friction with my wife that's
why they're playing this thing i see it
i look at the clock and i say they've
got a few more tapes to play maybe we
can get to noon at least i might be able
to defuse this a little bit if i get to
lunch break before they play this and
warn her that this is coming after lunch
sure enough we got there okay they
didn't play it yet i take the book i tap
her on the knee i show her look
they're gonna play this after lunch just
want you to know i was joking
she looks up at me and she says what are
you
that was all that's what she said that's
hot yeah
nothing wrong with her she's a trooper
by the way she's a trooper she's
unbelievable yeah yeah no halle berry is
beautiful but of course that was never
going to happen but see when they play
that stuff out of context and that's all
that's there
and then they start telling the public
that these things are somehow illegal
you're
yeah my uh thank you yeah so
great segue and now
shout out to halle berry if she's
watching uh
um
you had mentioned that and clearly
everybody knows this politics is a very
dirty business beyond and you got caught
up in it as bad as anybody
um
but what you dealt with is that just hey
it's politics as usual hey welcome to
the game
or is there something specific about
chicago illinois politics
than dirtier than most states i think
four governors of the state of illinois
have been in jail including the governor
preceding you governor ryan uh your arch
nemesis uh mike madigan i believe his
name is embroiled in political turmoil
you see what's going on in chicago and
you know they calling it shy rack and
just everything that's that's happening
there my question is what the hell is
going on in chicago and in illinois yeah
the answer is is it worse corruption
more endemic in a place like chicago and
illinois than in other places the answer
is yes and no
it is far more so than let's say our
neighboring state to the north wisconsin
their politics their government's a lot
cleaner no doubt about that but it's not
that different from washington that's
the sad reality i mean you think about
the stuff that happens in chicago mike
madigan they all got rich
madigan's the former speaker been
speaker since 1983 been a state rep
since 1973 the same time biden became a
united states senator right well both of
those guys got super rich in the job how
does that happen if you're doing it
straight right so when i think about
biden and hunter biden the allegations
relating to the biden family in china i
think about the bush family in china and
their economic interests i think about
going to war in iraq and we would lie to
about weapons of mass destruction and
dick cheney's the vice president and
halliburton and they break that country
up and then he his company gets in there
to rebuild it i think about that sort of
stuff and i think chicago and illinois
isn't that much different from
washington there are states that are
much
better straight cleaner
illinois is not one of them but it's not
that different in washington than it is
it's funny i just pulled the illinois
the most corrupt states in america okay
you got to see this type in the
following word
uh the most corrupt states in america
it's a
forbes article the most corrupt states
in america
it's it's by a mile there you go click
on that one go a little lower go look at
that make it make it bigger number one
is dc look at that
number of federal public corruption
convictions per 10 thousand inhabitants
from 1976 to 2018
dc's like the wayne gretzky of
corruption you know they're just
crushing number two they're not even a
state
no it's not and then it's illinois third
then tennessee new york pennsylvania
virginia ohio jersey uh georgia next on
that list and so these aren't red or
blue it's not like they're all blue
states or red states so how do you
interpret this uh map right here
you know
i don't really know a lot about what's
going on in louisiana i'm not surprised
with some of the history there right
a lot of it is tradition and customary
practices okay
and illinois customary practices here
again i'm the only one who didn't get
rich in that business because i wasn't
like those other people they do it
through legal corruption they pass the
laws that benefit themselves their law
practices and they get really rich
but
i would say this about illinois illinois
is so corrupt politically that even our
u.s attorneys can be corrupt like those
corrupt who did to me what
they did they're dirty rotten scumbags
and they're corrupt and they abuse the
rule of law and instead of going after
the real corruption
and maybe what's happening now with
madigan that's happening instead of
going after the real corruption they
went after a guy so they can look like
they did something because i had a high
office and they make names for
themselves and they just add another
governor to the list of the trophies
that they win
in that recording you said maybe i
should just come back and listen to mel
bell and you know not even done any of
that stuff and just kind of you know
melbourne being your uh uh
your uh not mel bill dick bell
father your father-in-law right who
helped you come up by the way a lot of
the things he played and you give him a
lot of credit for him helping you come
out but then you guys had a falling out
once you became a governor where he felt
like he no longer had influence over you
and you were kind of becoming your own
man and you were doing your own thing he
couldn't get any influence and then he
turned on you
and that kind of led to you getting
arrested would you agree with that very
much so he had a landfill you see my
father-in-law
look i love him strange is this yet he's
i think had a big hand in what happened
because he had a landfill that was
operating in violation of illinois
environmental rules i learned about it
and i had to make i had to act and i had
three options i chose to shut it down
let him go to court clean up the
environmental issue let the court decide
what should happen but in the meantime
as we were exploring this and learning
about his issue he was threatening me
through third parties if i shut this
down he's going to do x y and z on all
the rest he ended up having mobsters
involved in the whole thing the whole
thing was rotten and dirty and i did my
job and i shut it down and he was back
down here in florida at the time
vacationing and he had a home in sanibel
island on the west coast and he called a
press conference he went to fort myers
and started bashing me and he detect one
of my good friends who was my top
fundraiser
saying that we were he was trading board
and commissioned appointments for 50 000
campaign contributions a big lie they
later on would retract because he was
being threatened with a lawsuit but once
he did that he unleashed the furies on
me the fbi got really interested and
within a month they were in my life
he started it and he knew it and he was
smart politically he's an old chicago
ward boss that whole system that i was
up against i married into it i love his
daughter
part of him i love too still in spite of
it all but he's a son of a man
and this is your father-in-law this is
his father and you're still married to
betty yes i'm still married to patty he
was over at the house on christmas eve
of course and he's how do you navigate
this nonsense you know what my christian
faith instructs me to forgive
you imagine thanksgiving how it's like
christmas the guy that puts you away is
your father-in-law you're still married
to his daughter well he wasn't the only
he is not the guy that put you but he
kind of came out in fort mcmurray but
you're saying he had a hand in it he did
he unleashed the furies he knew what he
was doing i don't think he anticipated
it would get as bad as it did i don't
think that but did he know that the fbi
is going to come calling when he makes
an allegation like that he's a seasoned
pro in chicago politics had been there
since the 1970s yeah he knew
well yeah a lot a lot of the a lot of
the stuff you got what did he get you
did did it start off with congress what
what what rolls the job before he became
a governor
yeah and by the way he was helpful to me
to get when i got started but it was it
helped his politics this wasn't exactly
uh you know here's my son i want to
groom him to be my successor i'm the
son-in-law
you know what i mean is you know as long
as my wife patty loves me i'm fine with
him but other than that he could care
less what happens to me right so his
political interests were such that he
needed a candidate to run for state
representative because in that chicago
old chicago ward boss world if you don't
have a state representative that's your
guy you're emasculated you're not such a
big tough boss
and so he was getting screwed by the
politics around him in the neighborhood
he needed a candidate he had somebody in
the family who was a lawyer
thought might be able to give a speech
i had a name nobody could say
we've expected to lose iran against the
12-year old covenant turned out i was
good at it and we won big and then all
of a sudden we had higher aspirations he
was very helpful to me in that race
helpful to me in my congressional race
than helping me in the governor's race
but the higher you go
the less influence somebody like that
has and he felt estranged but the
problem was that landfill and
anyway it's it's very complicated
i'm telling you man my next life i want
to be you i do not want to what a life
you've lived well let me let me go back
to this so
some say
you
had many like strong aspirations of one
day being a president was that true like
you wanted to be president one day
you know yes and no you get you become
the governor people start talking about
you that way
i wasn't saying it they were talking
about me that way
and uh
look anybody who's up that high in
politics looks at the next position so i
wouldn't say i wasn't interested in it
but let me say this i honestly thought
and this might sound like but
for the first time in my life i was in a
position governor chief executive of a
big state with real power to actually do
real stuff for people i'd spent six
years in congress i think i was a good
congressman but you don't have a lot of
influence there especially when you're
new and young it's seniority has a lot
to do with it and it's also a collective
body so it's not like you can just do
things
now suddenly for the first time in my
life i've got power
i was the youngest in my family so i
never carved the turkey or you know my
my father locked harvested thanksgiving
dinners now here's something i'm the
governor of illinois i could actually do
stuff
if i wanted to if i was pursuing a
presidential path
and that was my big aspiration i
wouldn't have ruffled feathers i
wouldn't have pushed the stuff that i
was pushing i'd have played nice with
all the political leaders and they'd
have been happy to kick me out illinois
and run me for president
if i was doing it that way frankly with
obama do all due respect
all show
no go i mean he gives a good speech
there's not a lot of substance there no
really achieved no real achievements for
people and he became the first black
president of american history a great
opportunity for our country to bring us
further together on race but he left in
his wake a country further divided on
race because he played
politics with that issue and he's made
our country a less united place in fact
a more divisive place at an angrier
place he could have been a great
president and he it up in my
opinion because he wouldn't invest
political capital in it so to answer
your question maybe the mistake i made
if it was being president only was that
i was truly trying to get stuff done for
people and and use my power that way
instead of just being nice with all the
politicians courting people and going up
higher
maybe that would have been the better
play and i would have gone to the white
house and not the house
you know a story comes out obviously you
know the story nbc chicago and you've
been talking about this non-stop for for
a minute rod blagojevich files lawsuits
seeking right to run for office again in
illinois right former governor of
illinois filed a lawsuit in august of
2021 arguing his civil rights uh were
violated when the illinois state senate
banned him from running for state or
local office more than a decade earlier
in 2009 the illinois general assembly
removed blagojevich as governor and
barred him from seeking elected office
in illinois ever again i think they even
put your name in there in federal civil
rights complained bogovic now 65
declared what happened to him was
unconstitutional because he was denied
the right to call witnesses and to
cross-examine the government's witness
the governor also claimed he was denied
the right to pres present evidence
especially certain undercover tapes and
as a result according to the court
rulings people have been denied the
right to vote who in the past
has had a similar situation like you who
went to jail did time came back and they
were able to run again and they went
back into office in some sort of an
office in the past has anyone ever done
that oh yes marion barry the washington
dc mayor
we have an alderman in chicago by the
name of walter burnett bank robber
by the way a great alderman been there
for 27 years he's been allowed to run
um i'm the only one that
expressly has been put in legislation
that says i can't run for anything and
there's a story behind that marion barry
what happened with mary he was caught
doing crack crack cocaine on tape and
then he came back and was elected mayor
again
in nineteen maybe you should have been
doing crack rather than uh he may be
selling a senate seat hold on no no no
there was never a sale of senate seat i
just gotta and sure july 22nd 2015 the
appellate court confirmed it they called
it routine political log rolling i was
vindicated on that um
okay so in 1916 by the way the socialist
candidate for president eugene debs got
something like 2 million votes in a
presidential race while sitting in the
state penitentiary in indiana so he was
actually able to run for president while
sitting in a prison cell in indiana
but
look
there was a story behind that too they
came to me after i was arrested the
political leaders in illinois that's how
cynical they are and they were offering
me a deal if i step aside don't pick a
senator
and temporarily become incapacitated
there's a law that allows a governor who
if he or she is sick can be
incapacitated temporarily lieutenant
governor assumes the responsibilities of
the office
they were going to extend that law to me
this is what the offer was if i agreed
to do this
then i could keep my pay as the governor
something like 170 190 000 a year my
security detail and once i clear my name
i can become governor again this is what
they offered me
i turned it down for many reasons but
and part of the deal was you can't pick
a senator
i turned it down for many many reasons
chief among them was i did nothing wrong
i'm not giving it at all
and they know i did nothing wrong
because this is legal politics that's
routine happens all the time
so i picked a senator which pissed them
all off i picked roland burst an
african-american respected person in
illinois politics for former attorney
general in our state i did it in spite
of the fact that every democratic
senator including joe biden hillary
clinton all wrote me a letter saying if
you send us a senator we're not taking
one and so i send this african-american
man there and for the first day they
wouldn't let them in it was like in the
age of obama our first black president
we had gone back to the early 1960s and
james meredith is trying to get into ole
miss they wouldn't let this guy in the
most exclusive club in the world the
united states senate well america
watched this on television and within a
day i think the african-american
community around the country sought the
democrats folded and he be they let him
in and held a dinner for him that night
typical politicians right
so when i was doing that they said to me
if you pick a senator we're going to
throw you out of office before groundhog
day and we're going to pass a law that
disqualifies you from running for
anything that's how that happened and i
argue it's unconstitutional directed at
me and i should have a right to run but
better than that the people of illinois
should have a right to vote against me
if they want i'm not interested in
running for anything necessarily the
first primary i'd have to win is my wife
she's made it clear if i run i'm doing
it are you saying you're not interested
even if you win this lawsuit are you
trying to tell me with all your
political acumen and every thing that
has been built up with you over the last
decade you have no interest in running
for public office again
look
because i don't believe it there's like
i i feel like i see yeah a a politician
a well-polished politician who has a
you know a a story where he's been
dragged through the mud and you have
something you have a chip on your
shoulder like pat said so even if you
win this lawsuit are you saying that you
don't want to run
okay i don't know if my wife's watching
this but let me answer this as best i
can okay because i'd have to get through
that because she's been clear if i ever
get in politics again i'm doing it with
my second wife and she's unbelievable
she did say that by the way she says it
repeatedly
what a wonderful wife she defied all the
odds nine to one odds when i was
arrested the vegas odds makers had it
that she would leave i know as a
statistical fact that a woman
and a man if a guy's in prison for four
years or more there's better than 90
percent chance she's out she leaves she
can't wait especially if he's got a lot
more time to do which was the case with
me
she's defined all aliyah she's a
wonderful mother best person i've ever
known i love her she's great
and she's gone through so much because
of the career i had she suffered greatly
so do i need to be a better husband and
think about her of course and that's the
first priority
in the event that i was somehow
successful in this lawsuit and i i say
somehow just because i've had nothing
but bad luck in that building but if
that happened are you asking me would
that wet my appetite would i be in
very interested in exploring the
possibility
i'm like one of those boxers who fights
into the 50s right you just can't get
out of that arena right
you want to get back in there and get
that title back so there is that element
i have
and i do look at chicago i look at our
horseshit mayor she sucks our city is
crazy with violence you're no fan of
laurie lightfoot she's a bad mayor i
actually like the fact that she's uh i
like the fact that she's a woman like
the fact that she's black i like the
fact that she's a lesbian i think that
qualifies her she's a former u.s
attorney
but she uh she's a terrible mayor and
she's given sounds like a woke dream
right there and she's and she's gone on
to this whole defund the police stuff
she's not backing the police we have
tremendous crime in our city and 75 of
the victims are black kids black people
and it's just tragic anyway to answer
your question if i won that lawsuit i
would of course be really interested i
might want to tippy toe and tap my wife
on the back on the shoulder and say
honey can we have a talk
and maybe see if perhaps maybe she might
have an open mind what would you run for
though if you could what would you run
for would you go center would you go
straight governor would you go mayor
what would you run for
well i mean you know i wouldn't really i
don't see myself being governor again
i'll tell them here chicago would be a
great job i'm not saying that i don't
want to make any noises or news because
it's
just
right now there's a lot of says i can't
do it so it's but that'd be a job that'd
be really challenging what would you do
differently than what she's doing right
now again with the whole shy rack thing
and you know every time you turn on the
news more murders in chicago july 4th
the new year chicago like it's just
constant what would you do differently
how could you change chicago i'd hire 10
more police officers i'd get them up
from around the community a lot of them
from the black areas the black
neighborhoods
train them
the way you're supposed to be trained in
other words i double the police force
i'd have the backs of the police and we
know where the gang bangers are and we'd
go out and arrest them
we're not trying to defund the police in
chicago just the opposite i dramatically
increase funding for the police
you don't sound very much like a like a
woke democrat to me i'm an orphan
democrat that's why i call myself a
trumpet
i think millions of others like me
across america are like this
what the you're the first person i've
ever heard use the phrase trumpocrat
obviously he you're the first person to
be fired by trump and then pardoned by
trump you're an exclusive company right
there what does it mean to be a trumpet
a trumperocrat is um someone who's still
on the side of working people everyday
people the silent majority forgotten
voices
um who recognize there is a ruling class
in america their elitist snobs and they
screw ordinary people they lie to them
all the time like that canadian prime
minister trudeau what a liar he is we'll
go into that in a minute maybe but
um
and that trump has started a political
movement
that he's that's part of the realignment
of american politics where a lot of
traditional working-class men and women
who voted democrat historically have
recognized the democratic party has
taken them for granted and in many ways
sold them out like
trade agreements with china and some
other countries that have sent their
jobs overseas
those types of voters have always been
the ones that have been the ones i
really fought hard for they were like my
mother and father
so i think
i would say that that's a trumpet cred
and i think
you know he's got his own style
everybody has her own style but uh
the actual movement that he started i
think is for real and there's a
political realignment that's going on in
america and i predict that our democrats
are going to see a tremendous loss of
black support in this next election and
the growth of the latino voters for this
new kind of politics that trump is
backing not the old-line republican
party of romney mccain or mcconnell but
the sort of new politics that trump has
created
i think you're going to see an increase
in latino voters eventually they're
going to become predominantly republican
voters i do believe that because they
work hard living the american dream
they're like the new italian-american
community in america and they're growing
the fastest growing community in all of
america so let's let's go through a
couple stories i want to get your
reactions on them so uh one there's a
story here from breitbart blagojevich
democrats very fearful of what i know
ex-democrat illinois governor turned
trumpcrat rod begovid said he believes
governor jb
pritzker tried to keep him in jail
because democrat establishment is afraid
of what he knows and what he will say
soon the ex-governor blasted pritzker
for reportedly calling trump not once
but twice requesting to keep him behind
bars jb called trump not once but twice
joining with the most republicans to say
keep him in don't let him out keep him
in don't let him out why did he do it
belgovich continued before it
foreshadowing his
willingness to expose the under belly of
his former party i truly believe it's
because jb pritzker governor pritzker
and some of the democratic political
establishment is very fearful they
they're very fearful what i know and
what i can say and what i'm likely to
say and what i will say soon that's why
i think
that he did that so what is it that you
know that they're afraid of well there's
a lot of things a lot of them are on the
tapes and that's one of the reasons why
those tapes are under seal so a lot of
the stuff that's on those tapes i can't
speak about except for the ones that
have been released
some of them actually illegally in
chicago tribune
was able to get tapes notwithstanding
the court seal and the republican
candidate for governor
used them against jb pritzker and our
governor in the race his race for
governor back in 2018
pritzker on the phone he called me up
and asked me to make him united states
senator so he's on the very calls
that uh you know ended up
sending me where i went
and
i politely had full discussions with him
about his aspirations to be a senator
told him it was unlikely that i'd pick
him had a good relationship with him
back then he asked me then if i could he
was shopping around for an office if i
could make him stay treasure because i
had the power to do that too and he
anticipated the vacancy of the trade
state treasurer's office i told him that
he had a better chance of me doing that
for him then the united states senate
nothing
illegal about these conversations but
within the conversation he was referring
to you know my desire to point a black
person to the senate as being a
political a problem my black problem he
called it which almost
indicates
certainly some insensitivity about race
and if you're these neo-race these
neo-racists
keep pointing to their fingers at
everything being racist i mean he'd
certainly be
one of their poster childs wouldn't he
for saying that i'm not saying he is i'm
just saying he said it
but i had a good relationship with him i
had pointed him uh he had supported my
opponent in the democratic primary for
governor 2002 but then when i won he
asked me if i'd make him the director of
the illinois human rights commission and
i did and as far as i know he did a good
job and then when calamity came after he
made those phone calls that phone call
to me and we talked politely
i understood that he was stayed awake
because everybody did and they were
right to do it because when you have
what you i have that's leprosy nobody
wants to come near that that's lest they
catch it
but then when i had been in prison for
all those years
and uh
trump was had publicly said that he was
going to let me out indicated he was
letting me out he called my wife patty
in july
of 2020 or 2019 that he was going to do
it
this was a little bit before his call on
that ukrainian phone call right
the five republican congressman
wrote president trump a letter saying
don't let him out and then pritzker
called trump twice
urging him not to do it and you know if
he wants to say publicly keep him in
he's a corrupt son of a and all
the rest i get the politics of that i
don't like it but i get it but you go
the extra mile to actually call the
president and try to keep him
to keep me in prison when i have young
children like he has and i'd already
been in prison for seven and a half
years why would he do that
i think because of the political fears
that they have on the things that i
could do and say
that would expose them some of that on
those fbi tapes i think
governor you you seem like you're in
pretty good shape right now yeah okay
i'm not better shaped than governor
that's my question actually have you
seen a picture of what governor pritzker
looks like let's take a look um so my
question to you as they pull up his
picture
seems like you're a fighter you've
mentioned that you're a golden gloves
boxer um pritzker doesn't seem to be
working out as much as you
uh my question is this politically
if you were to fight him who would win
and then if you actually stepped in a
ring with governor pritzker who would
win that fight
well i may be a no-brainer right that'd
be no contest
hillary would be a tougher fight than
him
you think you'd knock him out what are
you saying go right last time i'd go
right to the body yeah right he'd bend
over
that's unfortunate you know i wonder why
that is with him i mean he was
inherited a lot of money to hide hotel i
said yeah the hyatt family pittsburgh
family i'm well aware who they are i say
things i shouldn't say and i'm going to
say it again i know this is wrong
because i shouldn't make fun of the fact
that he's we have a chubby governor
rotund
beyond rotund but he was born with a
silver silver ladle in his mouth and
and that's not right and the reason i
say it is because of what he did when he
called trump to keep me in otherwise
i wouldn't make fun of him like that but
in if i step away and try to be good as
i should try to be
i feel bad for him that can't be good he
shouldn't be like that he should spend
all that money and time to
you know
take a walk and do it consistently it's
not good for his health and i think the
stress of the office is is partly
causing that yeah i think and
politically how do you think you would
match up against him let's say you could
run again for governor i assume he's
going to run again for re-election yeah
how would you uh fair against him in a
democratic primary sure
i think i could be really competitive i
really do now he's got you know he spent
170 million dollars with his own money
that he inherited to win governor the
first time 170 or 175 million by the way
if i was going to sell a senate seat
isn't he my guy
i mean this is the guy he would have
bought it because he wanted to be
something he asked me to make him
senator then he asked me to make him
treasure he just wanted to be something
and uh if i was what they said i was
this is my guy i could have you know
given him a discount 30 million i will
say that he is giving you a run on a the
great head of hair campaign both of you
governor former governors
killing it in the hair game what do you
say to that
yeah good i mean look i missed the old
jb that i used to know and like i mean i
never realized he was has that mean
streak that he has and by the way he's
been a terrible governor too and the way
he's mishandled the kova situation he's
politicized that
and uh
in such a way where people in illinois
don't trust him
and it's not unlike some of the other
governors too they
they don't practice what they preach
they're big hypocrites and they don't
lead by example or join in the shared
sacrifice and when you're asking people
to make sacrifices you should be the
first one making those sacrifices right
how closely are you following this story
with uh durham uh hillary trump are you
following pretty closely yes because i i
recognize that stuff you know it so i
want to see it from your perspective
because we've read the other side of
stories the one that's from fox news or
breitbart or daily wire i want to read
you
wapo's uh perspective on what happened
here we read the vanity first what were
hillary's like i didn't do anything you
know here's what they're trying to do to
spin job you saw her speech she gave
last week in regards to durham
but here's the wahpo story about it how
the right embraced the false claim that
hillary clinton spied on president trump
the group includes anonymous twitter
accounts such as one called technofog
conservative journalists such reporters
for the epoch times red state former
administration officials fox news
newsmax then led the charge on
conservative television often in
misleading ways in many ways the
highlighted phrase executive office for
the president of the united states
formed
the core of the conservative news
coverage uh that a lot that followed a
claim that democrats had spied on trump
even when he was president but durham's
filing which is written
uh and confusing pros
did not actually say that trump's
internet traffic had been monitored
during his presidency rodney jaffe tech
executive one who's not been charged as
an internet entrepreneur who founded the
world's first commercial internet
hosting company sometimes some
statements by jaffe spokesperson to and
sussman's legal team insisted that the
data sussman provided to the cio 2017
meeting pertained to the time before
trump became president when barack obama
was still
president so
what do you know about story how much
credibility is there behind the story
which story that durham oh durham yeah
oh i think
every bit of it i believe every bit of
it my regret is it's gone so slow
i think it's gonna if they do this
honestly you're gonna find a lot more
people involved
here's what i think really happened i
think this was opposition research by
the hillary for clinton presidential
campaign it was conducted by the law
firm perkins and cui which incidentally
represented me on my political stuff
campaign finance stuff and things like
that prominent democratic law firm they
got this guy steel to drum up a fake
dossier and all that stuff they said
about trump and russian collusion and
having sex with prostitutes
i mean this is really familiar when
you're in that ugly business like
politics you see this yet some people
will do that on the other side they'll
cross lines and do it
and
you know let's i mean i think most
people would agree who understand
hillary clinton and bill clinton those
guys they played not her
she and him they play hardball politics
so the whole thing was predicated on a
big lie manufactured by them for
political reasons and then trump won in
spite of that
and they were determined to
destroy his presidency and in effect
cause a coup d'etat and having been a
victim of one myself i recognize it when
they're doing to somebody else
and you know obama and biden were in
meetings with general flynn
and and early on after
the during the transition period and
suddenly
flynn is facing criminal charges
the whole thing seems
to be part of a concerted campaign to
undermine the succeeding president they
didn't really want him
the irony is
they didn't accept the outcome of that
election in 2016 and from the very
beginning we're out to destroy his
presidency and destroy him and they
still are
rod you hear the story when people say
you know politics is such a dirty game i
mean how many times have you heard about
how many people everybody says that
right again five times on this planet
30 game it's a 30 game it's a dirty game
how dirty is it really for a guy that's
been on the inside how dirty of a game
is politics i did 2896 days in prison
that's how dirty it is it's
dirty i didn't break a single law i
didn't care you know and i'll never stop
saying it because i didn't it was a
political hit
i believe the evidence would show if i'm
allowed to
dig deeper into it that the u.s attorney
was politically motivated and it worked
with the democratic house speaker on the
impeachment against me
and i think that we have a real
dangerous problem in america forget
about me what happened happened but
moving forward we have a real problem
with federal prosecutors with
uncontrolled power no checks and
balances on these people they have
unlimited resources they can terrorize
and destroy people
make people say certain things that they
don't say they'll destroy them so they
say things against somebody else they're
using it now against political leaders
if you've got a politician who's taking
cash in a brown paper bag throw his ass
in prison of course but they're
criminalizing things that aren't crimes
russian collusion the sale of the senate
seat it's like they went to the same
madison avenue advertising firm to come
up with these clever names and the media
they're such
they're all about the advertising
dollars rather than do their jobs and
seek the truth they're out running with
these narratives and they create a
political environment that inevitably
leads to what you saw with trump and
then would be it with trump it was
polarized and divided between the
parties attempt to throw a president out
and teach him on nothing
he had nothing to do with any of it in
fact it came from the other side
and then the second impeachment on
ukrainian phone call
maybe
you know it wasn't polite but nothing
illegal about that phone call in fact
the president united states has an
obligation as the chief law enforcement
of america if he has reason to think
that the former vice president united
states and his son are doing
kinky stuff in ukraine
and get and getting wealthy on it he has
an obligation to look into it does he
actually he does
yes he's the chief law enforcement of
the united states he has an up
responsibility to the constitution if
there's reason to think that somebody's
doing something that's illegal you have
an obligation to look into it
being that politics is such a good
question yeah yeah being that politics
is such a dirty game and i know we've
alluded to the fact that you know maybe
you would run again if if your wife
would be so
gracious sorry um if you could
because again i i'm going to go back to
the fact that i think you're a brilliant
politician whether people
you know love you hate you whatever
you're you got that that it factor
but
if you could
build
these days
the perfect politician
someone who
can withstand all the drama social media
you know bring the country together
who would you like if you could take i
could take a little of jfk i would take
trump's you know arrogance i would take
brahma's eloquency is there how would
you build the perfect politician today
for president
yeah it's a great question and i could
in other words a little bit abraham
lincoln a little bit of franklin
roosevelt a little bit of ronald reagan
right
um yeah i think he could piece certain
things together
reagan's ability to talk to the american
people would be
one skill set that would be very helpful
soothing calming
trustworthy you know it's interesting
when reagan was president if you pulled
people on the specific positions reagan
took on most issues they didn't agree
with them but they trusted him so i
would say that would be a piece of it
clearly lincoln his kindness is goodness
and his strength there's elements of
that franklin roosevelt's ability
to uh
articulate and lead i'll give obama
points there as well maybe take some of
that
um but ultimately to be a great leader i
believe you got to have it inside of you
and the toughness inside gets revealed
by the circumstances and the events of
the time that you have to face
lincoln rose to the challenge and showed
a real toughness inside franklin
roosevelt did the same thing one's a
republican one was a democrat during
times of great crisis
some of these you can take obama's
eloquence and his ability to give a
speech but underneath that
there isn't that greatness that those
other two have
and
if i were to say
the ideal
combination i would frankly if i were to
limit it i would say lincoln and uh
franklin roosevelt both great
communicators in their own way who do
you think is the the best up-and-coming
politician obviously you know trump has
been there biden's been there bernie's
been there nancy pelosi has been there
you know
john mccain i mean the list goes on on
mcconnell these are guys in their 70s
80s who in their 40s do you look at and
say damn that guy's got it or that
girl's got it who who comes to mind
these days the young up-and-comers
i don't know that we know who that
person is yet
it could be somebody from outside of
politics i do think that more and more
people who are outside of politics could
be helpful to the system
i do think this though i would say
you know i
i i
america is so divided when i came home
so much has changed i didn't recognize
my party
you know it was uh
eight years that i was gone and you know
social media all this stuff is so
different now right
everything is so quick and
people have all these views it was just
important that they have those this idea
of cancel culture and this wokeness it's
a very different thing and a very
dangerous thing i think i think freedom
is in danger in the united states
and i think that
the hyper partisan nature of our
politics
is making things worse not better and i
don't know that i have a direct solution
to it because both parties are sort of
locked into their positions
it's all about winning the next election
i do think the republicans going to have
a very good year
2022 and i do think there's a
realignment going on in american
politics which could be very helpful and
get us back on a good track
but i i think the hyper partisanship is
so extreme
that it's just turning off too many
people and dividing us too much it would
be nice to see some person come out who
might be able to find a way to unify
without
selling out his or her
principles
and so a guy like reagan had that
ability roosevelt had that ability
lincoln had that ability
somebody like that do i see anybody in
the horizon right now i don't i'm
obviously very biased towards president
trump for what he did for me
i mean i think stylistically
you know he is what he is some people
love it some people don't
but i do think that
a lot of the stuff he's been working at
and talking about
is right for america
you know the more i'm thinking about
this and you know he's saying what he's
saying fdr you know
uh lincoln assassinated reagan attempted
assassination you know these guys
franklin roosevelt did you know that
yeah franklin and then jfk same yeah you
know a lot of these guys who push the
envelope yeah they have a target on them
right now today assassination is a
different kind of assassination you got
character assassination which is worse
sometimes than
you know some may say is worse than the
actual assassination right can i say
something about that sure
during my troubles
look you know i make light of it right i
mean but those were hard years
and when you got this and they're
they're after you like that and they
have all that power you know deep down
you're dead but you're going to go down
fighting
i would frequently find comfort late at
night when i try to fall asleep and i'd
imagine myself walking in that federal
court building and someone rescuing me
from what i was facing by walking up to
me and shooting me dead in other words
assassinate me i'd much rather have that
than what they were doing to me because
a timely assassination
it's good for your obituary and people
remember you in a more positive way but
being sent to prison for corruption when
you didn't do it
seemed to me a far worse result and so
when you call this the new kind of form
of assassination you're speaking to me
because in my own mind my preference
would have been the other then rather
than what ultimately happened now i'm
finally through it it's over and i'm
lucky i guess i'm glad i wasn't
assassinated because i believe in second
acts but you hit it right this is the
new form of assassination now this
politics of personal destruction would
use of fake criminal charges to get
people yeah so so this this almost makes
me not trust people that are career
politicians it almost makes you think
like what do you have to do to be a
career politician
not not not somebody that comes in does
the job and leaves okay i'm just gonna
come i'm gonna do two terms i'm out of
here okay i did my time a one of my
rules i follow on our family is make
your money after you make your money
take care of your family and once you
can take care of your family go get back
to public service in one way or another
be a mayor be a congressman be a center
to be governor do something and then
leave right matter of fact the shorter
you're in the more i trust you
the longer you're in i trust you less
because
how many deals do you have to do behind
closed doors how much do you have to
play the game
you know in some industries tenure is a
respectable thing to do right in some
industries you think about it's a
respectable thing to do
some industries
like politics i think tenure it almost
works backwards
because you eventually are going to have
someone that's going to show you
something that they're going to try to
uh hey if you don't do this we're going
to introduce this to the we're going to
send this to new york times oh we're
going to say this about you we're going
to tell this to your wife we're going to
tell this your kids we can tell this to
your family to rooney and you're tempted
to say
okay what do you want me to do i
need you to do this and then they have
you forever right
that's what i mean when i say how ugly
is politics not what you went through i
really want to know how ugly is the
job of being a politician as a career
politician
i think one of the biggest problems in
america is the fact that we have a
permanent ruling class
made up of career politicians
lobbyists
former
congressmen and senators who are
lobbyists
permanent staffers who are all over
washington i call it the political
industrial complex
it exists in washington dc it exists in
state capitals across america presidents
come and go governors come and go these
people are there forever and when they
leave congress they're lobbyists so
there's the same people and they talk
amongst themselves and their worldview
becomes that world not where the rest of
us live the other side of the potomac
they make good money 5-6 million a year
no doubt about it it's very wealthy it's
and they protect themselves they
support themselves on the backs of
everybody else in america it is the
permanent ruling class of these career
politicians against we the people
and that's part of the realignment
that's happening in politics that's why
it's changing and so that's there's a
lot of anger understandably so
um
and it exists in both parties no one
party is
more guilty than the other they're both
very much part of that and what's
interesting too is that
um
you know the idea of term limits for
example when i first became a state rep
in 1993 i supported that
and the guy that was pushing it would
ultimately be my lieutenant governor he
was the state treasurer at the time
he pushed it just to put his name on a
bill so he could say it was for but he
didn't care to even try to pass it
there's a lot of that baloney goes on in
politics then a lot of these guys that
got elected in 1994 republicans promised
term limits they were going to limit
themselves when they got eight years
when they got close to eight years you
know by then people forgot the promise
and they made excuses and they stayed
but i do think term limits is something
that should be seriously looked at and
you know the irony here is
our first president one of the greatest
americans of all time george washington
was all about what you just said
he served two terms and that was it he
could have been king he didn't want to
be king he could have been a three-term
president he didn't want to be
three-term president he believed like in
the old days of the roman empire that
this
cincinnatus he was a farmer he'd leave
the farm and go serve
his country and then go back to farming
until the soil that was what
washington's view was of american
politics and he set an example very
early on but over time that example is
forgotten and now you've got joe biden
as president who's been there
get this now he was 29 years old when he
was elected 30 when he was sworn in
constitutionally
youngest
age he could be senator
his whole adult life has been in
washington how could he possibly really
understand the fact challenges that
everyday people face because he's been
so far away from it and just the
opposite he's a creature of that swamp
and it is a swamp it's the same old
people and it's them against us let me
let me ask you you know you know when
sometimes you say there's crooked cops
right
and then you well you know there's
crooked pastors right there's crooked
preachers you know there's crooked
accountants there's
you know greedy uh capitalists hillary
whatever what i'm saying is
is the percentage of crookedness higher
in the job of a career politician than
any other occupation that's what i want
to do you know someone i'm asking yeah
exactly what i'm trying to do there's
always a few bad people always in every
industry but i wonder if the percentage
of bad up
on politician is higher than other
industries what would you say to that
i'd say yes and i'd say part of it is
because a lot of the crookedness is
legal
they make the rules that benefit
themselves
remember that
the rules are unfair and wrong but they
benefit themselves and therefore they're
legal but it's crooked because it ain't
right
who's the most crooked is it the actual
uh senator representative is it the
lobbyist is it the campaign finance
person is it the person pulling the
strings is it the people donating the
money is it the koch brothers is it
george soros like who is the most
corrupt in all this well i think it's a
system i think they it's a system and a
lot of the things that you're referring
to the people you're talking about
aren't breaking laws they're just
involved in the way the system is set up
people don't like the idea of public
funding for elections okay
but i wonder if that would not be a
better play where you take money
completely out of politics
because you
they pander to their political donors
and the new politics now is you have
these grassroots contributors
and obama started this at first i
thought this was a very good new
development because he was able to
encourage people every day people to
send small dollar checks and bernie made
his that's his mark and uh aoc now right
but on the political right president
trump raises a lot of money that way and
a lot of conservative republicans do so
initially i thought this was really
going to be good because it's giving
people everyday people more of a voice
but here's what it's done it's created
further division because if you even
look like you're you have an open mind
about the other side's point of view
you're going to run the risk of losing
your toners they won't send you checks
anymore
so it's almost better for you to be even
more strident against the other side and
both sides will do this because it
generates support among their donors i
don't think that's going to change
anytime soon i don't need and the reason
why i don't think it's going to change
any time soon is the following what
percentage of career politicians what
percentage of our politicians today and
i'm talking congress senate uh governors
okay take those three what percentage of
them
have been in politics more than ten
years
is majorities over ten years or
majorities less than ten years more than
ten years okay so
what percentage would you say is more
than ten years sixty percent seventy
percent sure seventy percent it's not
going to happen you know what i'm saying
when i say it's not gonna happen they're
in too deep
you're in too deep there's so that's
what they do yeah it's not like a young
freshman senator i'm going to come in
and i'm going to change washington i'm
going to do one of two things i have a
backseat buddy yeah they're going to
they're either going to
they're either going to uh you know
destroy the guy's reputation or they're
going to fall in love you know or
they're going to say you have two
choices bro you have to follow online or
we're going to do this to you which one
do and there's got to be somebody that
goes and has that conversation with them
it's a tough gig but the differentiator
these days is social media look at aoc
yeah she hasn't exactly fallen in line
with nancy pelosi or anything like that
so
you know look at tulsi gabbard you know
just
social media these days is the great
equalizer before you left politics it's
a very good point social media wasn't
really that prevalent so now if if
people don't agree with you it's like
all you guys i'm going to my
millions of followers to raise money
matter of fact that's what aoc just did
here's a newsweek story aoc slams tucker
carlson as trash
after he calls her rich white lady
representative aoc has referred to fox
and so tucker carlson has a creep after
he falls falsely claimed that she was
not a person of color but instead of
rich and tidal white lady carson
insisted
uh that aoc was white despite her shade
while discussing the upcoming book take
up space the unprecedented aoc carlson
took exception to the book books author
writing that the congresswoman had fully
out loud white female
asking whether they are referring to a
trans thing because arguing that no one
has done more personally to the great
american womanhood aoc responded by
sharon clip of carlson making the claim
to twitter alongside the caption this is
the type of stuff you say when your name
starts with a p and ends with a dejo
okay and referring to the spanish
language term pendejo right is what
she's talking about but
what do you think about aoc and her rise
she's come up she's got nearly 50
million twitter followers and when she
talks she gets millions of views how do
you think that happened she's a
generational leader she's speaking to
her generation i have two daughters my
older one 25 not exactly all in on aoc
but our politics not on that
unlike some of that
bernie sanders type
socialist politics that sounds good but
realistically is ridiculous doesn't work
um but she's a generational leader and
she's taking full advantage of the the
new mode of communication through social
media
what she's saying there though is an
example of how these elitists and she's
now become part of the elite she's got a
different backing but she's part of the
elite now how these elitists
want us to believe stuff that we know
our common sense tells us isn't true
so i mean if you look at aoc
tucker carlos is not altogether wrong in
how he said what she is i mean she's
from the suburbs came from a nicer area
it wasn't raised in the bronx where she
represents
and uh
and
can you say this but she's looks to me
when i see her she's she has light skin
so she's saying she's a woman of color
but she seems but is is he making the
same mistake that you admitted making
the same mistake when you said that you
were more black than obama she's
light-skinned i think she looks hispanic
yeah i i don't like definitely latina
i'm just saying this goes down to the
neo-racism weight race card
i know you have strong feelings on that
is that
i'm just putting that out there she
can't she capitalizes off of
opportunities like this she's a total
capitalist you have to realize yeah
except her method of capitalism is
different
she capitalizes off any moment to play
the victim card to get her audience to
say
you know he's a he's this and hey this
is why we need to come together she's a
very
very good young up-and-coming star of a
politician she's a very good politician
you got to give it to less than 10 years
clearly
most politicians 70 percent i think do
not be how they pull up her age right
now she's 32 right now i think she's 32
or 30 um
you know her name keeps coming up
uh uh
h aoc age is 32 yeah she's 32 october 13
and she's a libra come on aoc we're five
days apart she's 32. what does that say
about her that
pat is very big in the horoscope what
does that mean that's the 30 that screws
it up
okay because there's no way you're going
to hurt that's balance there's nothing
about her that's balanced she's not
she's not one that's willing but is this
the new
politician someone that doesn't bend for
their party that just builds up a
massive social media i mean you can
compare to being like a jake paul or
logan paul
where they're like look i don't give a
about you dana white ufc i don't
care about you boxers i got my own
following i'm gonna go make my money the
people are gonna follow me and get in
line or or don't get in line i'm doing
my own thing it's social media has been
the great equalizer these days look at
her career right now no i think that's
right what you're saying is right and
she speaks for a generation she's she's
appealing and i could see where people
you know would follow her but
i think what chugger carlin is carlson
is saying i i want to defend him only
because
it's my understanding she was raised in
the suburban area
not ex in the bronx in the hood like
she's claiming or she maybe she doesn't
claim it but
and while she has every right to express
her views and
and support the people of her uh
community and seems to be doing that in
many ways because that district as i
understand has always been real far left
um
she's in some ways
what she accuses other people of being
privileged
she's
doesn't come from there and so she's she
has skill and talent privileged side i
get yeah is she privileged that wasn't
she a waitress before this uh
she was working
i think she was working at starbucks as
a
you know barista just like 10 years came
from money or anything like that clearly
not the the thing they were talking
about the other day she was flying first
class and uh she booked a flight on
first class and
she was getting keyed to say now you
don't want to sit with the common people
you want to sit in the first class with
rich people she's going to get and the
reason why she's going to get that hate
girl from bronx aoc who beat high
ranking democrat joe crowley faces
questions over her working-class
background after it's revealed she grew
up in a wealthy suburb north of new york
city
uh this article was like five years ago
it is five casio twenties associates
doing work in class clemson a 40 minute
commute from bronx to scholarship but
her architect father uh uh bought a
house in wealthy westchester county in
1991 ocasio-cortez went on to attend
boston university intent
uh interned for ted kennedy yeah there
you go well i stand by what i say that's
not representative of the bronx i mean i
came from the city of chicago i wish i
could have been an intern for a u.s
senator when i was coming up before i
went to college now i'm not i don't mean
to say that this is some negative thing
about her but
she's
she's had some
that part of the democrat party points
their fingers at white guys and other
people for being privileged
and yet their background is
no different of the very people that
they point fingers at that's that's the
only point i'm trying to say but if
you're asking me she's a new form of
political leader today no question about
it she is and social media gives
people up where whatever their political
viewpoints might be a certain freedom
where if they can build up support like
you've done here with your podcast you
can be a separate individual entity and
independent and that could in the long
run run
maybe serve our democracy in a good way
well the analogy there is like we are no
longer beholden to the mainstream media
exactly or the mainstream big government
if you can create your own lane like a
pbd exactly or like a rogan or like an
aoc the world is yours exactly today
it's
this is the only difference though you
have to realize what's going on today
which is scary
uh today for the first time
40 years ago complainers didn't have the
mic
40 years ago you didn't hear complainers
having a mic we heard from doers is what
it was right
whoever spoke was a doer whoever had the
limelight was a doer today
the world is a little bit confused
because complainers can get up there and
sell a great argument in a convincing
way and recruit other complainers
and they that mic today is very very
loud and they're better recruiters and
doers here's why a lot of times a doer
will do the following here's here's the
weakness of a doer the weakness of a
doer is the doer eventually goes and
says you know what i don't even want to
you know that whole argument if you are
seen arguing with a
you know if you wrestle with a pig you
know uh
how does that saying go if you wrestle
with a pig you're gonna get some mud on
you yeah you're gonna end up being the
same thing right so so a lot of times if
you argue with somebody that's just a
you know person that makes no sense
others are sitting there saying why are
you even defending yourself right argue
with an idiot and look in the mirror
basically yeah you are deity so why are
you associating yourself with an idiot
so a doer will say you know what i'm
good man i'm going to leave but this
guy's not going to stop talking to
complainer the complaint is going to
keep going going go go
and others will interpret that and say
did you see the complainer had a point
he won because the other guy walked away
when in reality the doer just said i
don't have time for you
i got to go build my business i got to
go in the arena i got to go get the hate
i got to go try to build a
economy so other people can have jobs
and see what i can survive and still
raise a family and still raise kids and
still do all the stuff that i'm doing so
the only difference today with the great
equalizer of the mic
is a complainer with a very um
persuasive way of communicating could
baptize more people into the mindset of
a complainer than a doer well i don't
know because let me give you a different
perspective sure because nobody
argues and debates with more complainers
than you
you have socialists and communists come
on and you have great arguments and
disagreements with them and one of the
things that you say is let the audience
decide because i would i would classify
a socialist in america today as a
complainer right
but
you're able to have these very impactful
conversations
and yeah they might make a point but
you're oftentimes going to make a way
more valid point and then the audience
can decide who really is the idiot in
that conversation do i have a point
there no you have a very good point
there i agree with you that there are a
lot of like listen take rogan rogaine
will bring anybody and have a
conversation with them right and the
audience has to decide
uh what they have to say and aoc today
her argument today
is creating momentum
because of what's going on i i can't
tell you how many parents i'm speaking
to and they say the following here's how
many parents i'm speaking to and i'll
say so what's your biggest struggle
right now with your kids oh my gosh my
daughter thinks aoc is her hero
my son
is obsessed with aoc it's their hero i
said there's nobody like someone you
know this young person here that's
coming up it's their hero it's their
hero right and and why
they're right you know when you talk to
the kids so tell me why are you why are
you such a big fan of aoc you don't
think these rich people and i always ask
an open-ended questions of these young
people that are between you know 18 17
to 28 years old i said what do you think
my capitalists
con
all they care about is money that's
exactly why aoc is going to go after
them that's why this and you're sitting
there saying got it and they have
wealthy parents and and not necessarily
wealthy parents but parents who are
upper class who are making money who are
going to school you know parents who
parents who tend to believe in
capitalism they tend to believe in
capitalism but they're but their kids
are being convinced by this so
again this tool social media
is allowing people to convert and
complainers sometimes
so i guess the challenge will be the
following so your question poses leads
to a challenge the challenge will be for
doers to be a little bit more louder
okay just like you yeah you know how
sometimes they say you know
uh
stop posting these pictures
i'm not gonna post anything okay i'm
gonna post a regular life that i don't
wanna do yeah so i don't wanna deal with
it right but you know what now you have
to keep posting
you have to keep posting because we have
to i want my kid to look up to a person
to say i want to go make an impact and i
want to go build a good life and you
realize the older you get money matters
more
it just does
money matters more the older you get
raising kids yesterday we have a couple
with our that was on the we're spending
time with them the afternoon i sent a
video to yesterday when i'm talking to
when i'm doing the face time with your
guy was sitting next to me
and you know the cost of raising kids
today the cost of having a family today
it ain't cheap today to have a family
it's a lot of work to have a family it's
very complicated to have family so i i
just think doers need to be a little bit
louder power to those who are doing it
who question everything well look at
elon musk there's no bigger doer than
him these days and that guy's got the
bully pulpit he and and he is so
incredibly important
and another guy that has to be
constantly challenged and protected
because they're going to keep going
after this guy you know respect to him
for not backing down he posted a picture
the other he's got such a great sense of
humor he posted a picture there go on
his twitter account he posted a very
funny picture the other day i don't know
if you saw it or not it was a picture of
1980s phone booth versus today did you
see that
go to that picture he posted gotta love
this guy's sense of humor right they
click on that
phone booth in 1992 yeah phone booth in
2022 it's not wrong he is not wrong not
for sure go ahead you were going to i'd
like to do a shout out to another group
of the fellowship of the doers okay i'm
in the trucking industry i work for this
company called cdl1000
owned by andrew sapko ukraine an
immigrant great american success story
like you
truckers
and the truckers up in canada freedom
fighters these people are hard-working
men and women go to work every day they
drive long lonely roads long hours
delivering the food we put on the table
clothes that we wear the building
materials for the houses we live in and
the buildings we we rent from
and now they're trying together to have
their voices heard
in their capital and they're facing the
elitist ruling class in canada
and yet i do believe that their example
it's frustrating to see how they're
being treated but their example is a
powerful example of doers people who
work hard
getting their voices heard you know aoc
in in that group of young liberals and
complainers as you say what a church
you'll say about young people if
you know if you're not a liberal when
you're young you have no heart if you're
not a conservative when you're older you
don't have a brain
i'm confident history will repeat itself
and our kids including my daughters will
have a little bit more common sense as
they have more life experience and god
bless her for what she's doing out there
advocating for her views
i'm not so sure she's living that
socialist lifestyle they advocate either
as bernie sanders because he's worth
millions isn't he
but
um
regular everyday people forgotten people
solid americans are starting to rise up
parents at school boards
truck drivers and candidates
it is great to see and they're going to
save our country and they're going to
put pressure on their political leaders
who are going to back down because most
politicians are afraid of the people
they don't trust the people and if the
people rise up and recognize they're
being lied to those politicians will
will hear them and they'll adjust what
do you think about the way trudeau is
handling canada
terrible like that guy's an elitist snap
somebody ought to kick his ass i
shouldn't say that i'm going to say i'm
saying something but he's over there
lying he's calling those truckers nazis
you might have some idiot out there with
a swastika but those are hard-working
men and women who love their country
they're not nazis and he knows it
they're doing talking points that come
from political analysts and consultants
and they put that stuff out there to
mislead the public
just like russian collusion and some of
the other stuff my own experience i can
see it i know it
so i don't like him at all i think he's
terrible and he's a a guy he's the son
of a former prime minister he's never
done any heavy lifting in his life he's
not even saying he's a former son of a
former prime minister minister pierre
trudeau was his father oh no no
i thought you were saying he's the son
of a former prime minister castro i
thought that's where he was
trudeau
trudeau former prime minister of canada
so he grew up as an elitist and uh
you know and living the good life never
did any real work and the idea that
truck drivers who do real work who bring
us the food that we ate and all the
other stuff that we need that he'd be
treating him that way offends me and
he's
he is a member of a political party in
canada that would be the member would be
the political party i was a member of
hearing ill in america did you see that
video with the with the the cops
trampled over that old lady the the
horse did you see that video i'm not
seeing the video can you play that video
it's very disturbing by the way
uh uh watch what happens here
what is happening here
what is this lady doing traveling
horses
[Applause]
they went over the lady
they just trampled that lady
they just fully trampled everybody this
is in canada this is actually truckers
you know you saw this in australia you
never thought this would happen in
canada but the the thing with
when you see these videos with cops i
can't believe
i have a hard time believing that all
these cops
fully agree with trudeau
so you know what i'm saying like i have
a very hard time believing that so
imagine the job that you have to do
but you disagree with the way the guy's
treating everybody there it's the same
as the ss in 1945 it's just they're
they're sitting back and they're quiet
you look at the video there was a from
the same uh protest there was a video of
cops beating a woman with the butt of a
rifle they the woman got pulled over
onto the side of the cops they were they
were on top of her and they started
beating her with the butt of this rifle
and it's like they're they're they need
to speak up and say something or else
they're going to become a real problem
and they're going to become the ss and
the brown shirts
it's because they're afraid to speak up
and speak their mind they just do what
they're told and obey the orders
you know it's like this
every everybody believes in back the
blue and i don't i don't debate that
right but you can only do that so far at
some point the blue have to stand up and
realize that they're more than just
um somebody who's given an order they
have to speak up and stand up and say no
this isn't what we signed up for this
isn't what we took our oath for this
isn't this isn't who we are yeah i mean
what are they going to do they're now
towing trucks now they're impounding
them
and they're hurting that's still going
to backfire on them because you need
those guys to keep driving these trucks
truck drivers don't have the most
luxurious
lifestyle you know they're they're not
around the most they're away from their
kids they don't see their wives and kids
for god knows weeks at a time days at a
time you need those guys to work those
are not people that you want to
discourage them from working everybody's
affected by it
what say you're putting up up there we
hear your concern for people on the
ground after the horses despair the
crowd
anyone who fell got up and walked away
we are unaware of any injuries a bicycle
was thrown
at the horse
further down the line and caused the
horse to trip the horse was uninjured
what are we supposed to do with that
this this is the
statement from ottawa police about
trampling the woman
that's how they responded to it
fascinating on what's going on over
there man how's the woman doing i'm glad
to hear about the horse but how's the
woman doing
it's the that's really disillusioning
your friend that you're working with in
logistics he's from ukraine how to
change
so what do you think is going to happen
to ukraine when you're seeing you know
biden saying hey if you don't attack you
know ukraine i will attend the summit
but if you do i will not
you know the ukraine prime minister
saying stop calling this and you're
scaring the hell out of my people just
leave it alone we got this putin's not
going to do anything we're in
communication
where are you at with that
consumer prices went up 7.5 in january
inflation is out of control people go to
the store every day and they buy stuff
they see
higher prices
put gas in the car they see it
they look to their leaders
and they understandably blame them
biden's facing this now his approval
ratings are really low his politics is
very bad
and
nothing like a good war okay to help you
in your domestic politics now do i think
biden is going to lead us into war over
ukraine i do not we will not go to war
with russia over ukraine do i think that
there's a real risk that russia might
invade the eastern part of ukraine yes
they did it in crimea it's very possible
um do i think biden is exaggerating the
threat and his administration is
exaggerating that so much so that when
he calls zelinski the ukrainian
president and zolinski tells them stop
scaring our people it's not as bad as
you're saying it is do i think that's
cynical politics by biden i do
um
if you're asking me to predict an
outcome i don't know that i have one
but i think
it's a combination of
putin wants to
flex his muscles and
and he's fearful of nato expanding
further with ukraine
and i think there are a lot of ethnic
issues in that part of ukraine
where historically if you know anything
about that part stalin had populated a
lot of russian nationals to that part of
the ukraine
during the
famine in the late 1930s with his failed
collectivization socialist policies that
were starving the ukrainian people
because
they weren't producing enough crops so
there's a real comment you don't think
nothing's gonna happen you think he's
just trying to uh he's bluffing you
think putin is just bluffing
i i don't
it's hard for me to predict an outcome i
don't know what the outcome is going to
be do i think it's possible he might do
it he did it in crimea he he could do it
do i think he's if i bet on it would i
say he's going to do it when he's facing
the economic sanctions that he'd be
facing
from
the united states and western europe
i would think he's not going to do it
and then i think part of what he's doing
too is he's causing up to china his
relationship with china to build a
stronger relationship with china because
i think russia putin and russia feel
they've been isolated in the power game
so i think it's a i'm hoping that it's
more posturing and positioning than an
actual invasion but if you're asking me
to bet on it
i don't know i don't know what the
outcome is tulsi gabbard said she warns
the military-industrial complex wants a
war in ukraine this is a political
insider story former congressman tulsa
gabriel former president eisenhower's
famous warning on saturday saying the
neocons war mongers have spent years
stoking the new cold war with russia and
have now brought us to the brink of
ukraine this serves their own interests
and lines uh the pocket of the
military-industrial complex with
trillions of dollars let's not be sheep
and then she told tucker later on what
we have unfortunately is democrats
republicans mainstream media the
washington elite essentially in the
pockets of the military-industrial
complex do you agree with that i think
there's a lot of truth to what she's
saying you know again
it's easy to be anti-russian in the
united states we were raised to fear the
soviet union and for many rightful
reasons
my father fled communism when he after
world war ii and didn't go back to his
native yugoslavia because he wanted to
come to a country that he perceived as
being free and mostly was
but
after the fall of the berlin wall and
after the dissolution of the former
soviet union promises were made to the
new russian country and their government
to yeltsin
by nato
about expansion nato expansion and while
poland
i think rightfully should be in nato and
some of the other countries and maybe
ukraine at some point that remains to be
seen
but a lot of these promises have been
broken and when the united states and
nato decided to break up a sovereign
country yugoslavia where my father came
from over kosovo when they decided that
they were going to force
a sovereign country to give up a portion
of its country
because of the ethnic situations there
they created a
precedent and they basically
told the russians you're of no
consequence because historically the
russians have always been allies of the
serbs and that part of the region with
the complicated politics of the old
ottoman empire your people have been
screwed
the armenian genocide and all the rest
and so when nato and the united states
decided to break up a sovereign country
the way they did
that was a message to putin and the
russians you can't trust these people we
can't work with them and so a lot of
what you're seeing is a manifestation of
those relationships that go back 25
years
so if you're asking me to predict an
outcome
i don't really know what she is saying
do i believe that absolutely i sat on
the house armed services committee and i
voted i plead guilty to this i voted for
that one iraq i remember sitting there
as a young congressman listening to
watching all these joint chiefs of staff
generals under oath testify classified
hearings about the weapons of mass
destruction that were there and i'm
asking myself i remember could they be
lying because if they were there that
seems like we should get in there and go
get those weapons of mass destruction
and get them away from saddam hussein so
if it's true i have to vote for this war
hillary voted for the war
and i remember looking at hillary i'm
thinking in myself could they be lying i
don't have enough experience here so i
want to look to see what other senior
members in the congress are doing who
would know better
and what better person than her she was
the former first lady and she was very
close to her husband when it came to the
governing side yeah she would know
whether or not these generals are lying
or not
well they lied right she voted for the
war i voted for the war bernie sanders
didn't i remember thinking man that
guy's something else he was right we
were wrong but we were lied to so when
tulsi gabbard says what she says about
the political industrial complex and
those neoconservatives who like to get
us involved in foreign
ventures and
halliburton those contractors and all
the rest do i believe it i absolutely do
do you think those generals actually
lied or the information that they
received from the people higher up
you know the military military
industrial complex was feeding them
misinformation because it's not like
these generals got rich off of this
right
no your point's well taken it's a lot
more complicated than whether or not
there's a blatant lie to you somebody
was lying along the way they may have
gotten a lot of misinformation faulty
intelligence
maybe just fake intelligence not sure
all i know is there were no weapons of
mass destruction there and we voted for
that war predicated on that someone was
wrong let's do it let's do speed round
so here's what i want to do this the
last thing that we'll wrap up we're
coming to the end of it here is i'll
give you a name give me one word that
comes to your mind okay andrew cuomo
andrew cuomo the former governor
he did it because if he didn't do it he
wouldn't acquit okay mark vargas i love
mark vargas mark vargas was the mystery
man who helped me come out of prison
trump
i love trump i love trump i got to know
him on celebrity apprentice
really liked him people don't realize
he's a real kind man when you know him i
saw him do things off camera that were
very kind he was very kind of my little
girls during a very difficult time
i love trump and by the way what he did
for me benefited him politically not at
all he didn't have to do that he gets no
benefit but he did it he saw something
wrong and ended it a lot of pop people
and politicians politics are not like
that trump's very different obama
very disappointed obama
um
i'll answer that by saying one of my
colleagues in prison after obama didn't
cut me loose
um asked me what about your friend garf
god what about your friend obama he
didn't give you a clemency my answer was
i'm never voting for that guy again
desantis
up-and-coming leader in the republican
party
um
he won't be trump trump would be him if
he runs he won't run trump's the big dog
right now in the republican party he
won't run he will not run against
interesting vic mill
my father-in-law who's been very good to
me in many ways very bad to me in many
ways
i love him
i do he's my father-in-law he's got a
lot of good qualities
um he's 83 years old and i marvel at how
well he's doing at 83 and i'm very happy
about that
rahm emanuel
i always like rahm ebanjo he's a tough
guy he's a doer
he's a member of the fellowship of the
tours that you talked about that teddy
roosevelt talked about
he's ruthless though very ruthless and
uh
the means justify the ends as far as
that guy is concerned
steven schwartzman writes in his book
you know who steven schwartzman is i
don't i mean he's a billionaire and he
says uh you know one time you know i got
invited to a meeting with rahm emanuel
and obama and he said we had the biggest
shouting match cursing at each other he
says i realized how strong rahm emanuel
was but i knew i had to learn how to
negotiate with this guy because he's not
going away he's on his on obama's
something in that emanuel family blood
his brother's like the biggest agent in
hollywood and there's another brother
who's like a physicist or something
no there's three of them as i understand
it there's the agent hollywood agent
there's rom and there's the ethicist and
i refer to the ethicist as the black
sheep of the family
how about anderson cooper
he wasn't nice to me when i came home
and uh so that was disappointing so uh
low marks for him okay bob menendez i
knew bob menendez when we were in
congress together and bob menendez
had had the law been applied to me my
case the way it was applied to menendez
my case would have been thrown out just
like his his case was the judge threw it
out for insufficient evidence i should
have got the same treatment george ryan
george ryan is an old school
illinois politician he was a republican
but pretty much like democrat machine
type values
he's an old man he's lost his wife
he did his time
i don't think that
he was innocent
fitzgerald patrick evil wicked
um
a man who has abused his power
to frame people
evil and wicked and i think he's done it
to a lot of black people too interesting
mike madigan
um
mike madigan all about politics and
himself
what
as cynical as they come politically
great skill hard worker very smart very
disciplined i think a good dad
um but he squandered an opportunity to
do a lot of good for people because it
was all about his power and he's hurt
illinois we're the highest tax state in
the nation because of him little caesar
madigan but he's gone now the berlin
wall is finally falling
and maybe if there's a new day in
illinois though with this pritzker as
governor it's not
it's not it's not okay so does future
look bright for illinois
as of today no is there hope in this
coming election yes
prediction for presidency in 2024 who
becomes a president donald trump you
think so very much so really yes what's
your level of certainty
68 percent 68 percent 65 percent what a
number what do you think biden runs
again
i don't think so what do you think
i don't think i don't think he'll be
there and i don't think kamala will be
there no no i don't think bryan runs
again i think trump wins
there's a historical precedent to this
in 1824
a strong leader like trump andrew
jackson ran for president
and the election was thrown into the
house of representatives close there
were four people in that race
jackson was the people's choice really
and it's same kind of constituency trump
has working people who felt disgruntled
by the elitists and the ruling class
it was stolen from at the capitol
because henry clay the guy that ran
forth made a political deal
supporting the son of the second
president john quincy adams was the son
of john adams in exchange for that he
became the secretary of state it was
called corrupt bargain
and that's what it was known four years
later all those jacksonians were
energized and ready to go and he came
back and won overwhelmingly
i think it's going to rip history he's
going to repeat itself with trump couple
more names for if we have time
being that you're the former governor of
illinois chicago comes to mind michael
jordan
i had dinner with michael jordan once
when i was governor he's fantastic of
course we love michael jordan i mean
michael jordan elvis muhammad ali you
can't get any better than that scotty
pippen
not so much
did you ever have the opportunity to
hang out with dennis rodman
no but you know dennis rodman and i have
one thing in common you know what it is
we both got fired from the apprentice
well said we both got fired by donald
trump on the celebrity apprentice
rod this has been great folks if you
have not seen the documentary we're
gonna put the link below for you guys to
go see it and uh what's the best way to
find you are you active on twitter
i am i'm on twitter uh real blagojoy
i think you're at real blagoy
i'm on facebook do you know what
my facebook stuff is we'd love you to be
i'm looking for the following all of
that stuff we got all those links in the
description to the lightning rod we will
put all of that stuff below having said
that i appreciate you for coming out
this was great really enjoyed it thank
you everybody bye bye bye
you